15:34 and the king of France is a bit
angry the King Francis the first of the
House of Valois was unhappy because
overnight posters had sprung up across
France denouncing Catholicism and its
practices as evil the king who is a
devout Catholic was horrified
mostly because he'd been quite tolerant
of the nascent Protestant movement up
until now and also because one of said
posters had been stuck to his bedroom
door Francis could no longer tolerate
Protestantism and so he rounded up loads
responsible and also some who weren't
responsible and burn them at the stake
the persecutions led to many Protestants
the most notable being John Calvin
fleeing to Switzerland his religious
persecutions continued throughout the
rest of his reign which would end in
1547 due to death he was succeeded by
his son henry ii who continued the
persecution of Protestants he created a
new court for the prosecution of heresy
called the burning chamber Henry wasn't
exactly a good friend to the Pope's
either though he boycotted the Council
of Trent the church his first attempt to
creating a united response to the rise
of Protestantism and he also stopped
giving the Pope money there were two
reasons for this the first was that
Henry wanted the response to
Protestantism in France to be a French
one and second the neighboring Holy
Roman Empire also had issues with
Protestants and Henry didn't want to
help the Hapsburgs why because war henry
had continued his father's wars against
the Habsburgs which came to an end in
1559 it was fairly inconclusive and to
celebrate peace henry decided to hold a
jousting tournament he opted to take
part in the jousting himself and swiftly
got a lance to the I he would soon
succumb to his wounds and the throne
pass to his young son who was crowned
Francis the second Francis was only 14
at this point and was technically old
enough to govern the actual running of
the realm fell to the uncles of his wife
Mary Stewart better known as Mary Queen
of Scots the two men running the kingdom
were Francis the Duke of G's and Charles
the Cardinal of Lorraine they were both
from the powerful Gea's family and were
ardent Catholics meaning that for the
Protestants burny burny time would
continue the two Jesus didn't simply
dominate the King without any resistance
Francis the second mother and the former
Queen Catherine de Medici vied for power
too so the Protestants also known as the
Hyuga nose felt that the King wasn't
really anti Protestant and that if they
simply liberated him things would get
better this culminated in the 1560
conspiracy of a moi and attempt to
kidnap the King from his residence the
conspiracy was betrayed most of the
plotters were captured and killed in too
many it's confirmed that the Huguenots
were the enemy of france one of the
leaders of the plot was a man called
Louis the
have calmed Conte was arrested but the
situation would become much more
complicated when Frances ii died in late
1560 Frances had no children and so he
was succeeded by his ten-year-old
brother Charles the ninth another young
king on the throne meant that yet again
factions vied for power over him it was
Catherine who won out in the end
becoming his Regent and swiftly removing
the geese from court she took a
different approach to the religious
divisions in France and opted for a
policy of toleration she released Conte
in 1561 and in 1560 - Catherine issued
the Edict of San Germain which gave the
Hyuga knows the right to worship so long
as it was outside of cities and so long
as they stayed loyal to the king for
many Catholic Nobles though this was a
step too far
one such noble was the Jew cookies you
promptly massacred a group of
worshipping Hyuga nose at the town of
Vassy both sites took up arms after this
and France descended into violence and
so began the first French war of
religion alongside the Prince of Kampf
the Hyuga notes were led by Admiral
Gaspard the colony the Hyuga know seized
major cities like all Leon Leon and
tours and within a few months these
lands were theirs the Catholic forces
counter-attack the Prince of Khan was
captured again in late 1560 - in the
next year the Duke of Keese was killed
by an assassin while seating only on
neither side could really defeat the
other and so in 1563 the Edict of Anwar
was signed which gave Hyuga nose a few
more rites so much as recognizing that
Hugin eyes were allowed to exist was too
much for many of the Catholics who
resisted the enforcement of the peace as
such Katharine and Charles went on a
royal tour of France to assert the Kings
independence and fourth the laws to
implement the Edict of Anwar by this
point Protestant rebellion had spread to
the Spanish Netherlands and so the king
of Spain philippe ii sent an amiga this
worried the Hyuga nose he wondered if
the spanish army was actually meant for
them after another failed attempt to
kidnap the king by the Prince of condé
in 1567 both sides took up arms and
suddenly second French war of religion
this war was a stalemate and in 1568
another peace was signed the Cardinal of
Lorraine strictly opposed any peace and
he and his allies in court overturned it
the next year Catholics took up arms and
third French war of religion the third
religious war was much bloodier than the
first - mostly because of foreign
support for both sides but yet again no
side could defeat the other it did see
the death of condole even calling you in
charge of the Hyuga nose piece was made
in 1570 in the Hyuga notes were given
near equality legally but the problem
remained the Catholic population of
France didn't want the Protestants there
the Hyuga nose were also now given
formal control over several important
cities the most notable being La Roche
colony soon after became a trusted
advisor to King Charles and thus
Katherine was sidelined Charles also
opted to have his sister married to the
Protestant King Henry of Navarre Navarre
in case you were wondering is here all
of the most prominent Yugi knows went to
Paris to attend the wedding on August
the 18th in 1572 four days after the
ceremony colony was shot but survived
tensions exploded in the city in two
days later on August the 24th st.
Bartholomew's day many Protestant
leaders including colony himself for
murdered this was followed by the people
of Paris taken to the streets of
murdering any Hugo knows they could find
over many weeks violent spread
throughout France and many thousands of
fugitives were killed in what is known
as the st. Bartholomew's Day Massacre
Henry of Navarre was spared there when
he promised to convert to Catholicism
the massacre severely weakened the Hyuga
no sight by depriving them of decent
leadership but still war number 4 broke
out it ended the same way nobody could
win in in 1573 they made peace the next
year another war broke out because at
this point why not during this war child
the knife died and Catherine took up the
Regency until her third son who had just
been elected the king of Poland
Lithuania could return to take the
throne he got back in 1575 and was
crowned King Henry the third his reign
got off to a great start when his
younger brother and heir Francis
rebelled against him and made an
alliance with the Hyuga nose Henry of
Navarre soon escaped the royal court and
properly unconverted from Catholicism
and was soon leading the Huguenots
rebels
no one could defeat the other peace
again you know the drill like every
other piece the King couldn't enforce it
furthermore the Hyuga nose refused to
disarm since the last time they done so
they were massacred
Henry thus decided that he would try
crushing the Protestants and so began
the sixth war it will shock you to find
out that no one could win this war and
another peace treaty was signed which
basically allowed Protestants freedom of
worship everywhere except for Paris
there was a brief seventh war from 1579
to 1580 and yet again the same thing
happened the king and his younger
brother had repaired the damaged
relationship and Francis did two things
one he got engaged to Queen Elizabeth
the first of England although she was
likely just using him as a pawn and two
he went to the United Provinces here to
help them fight the Spanish forces and
become their king
he was completely useless at this he
didn't get married because Elizabeth was
too smart for that and he returned from
the Netherlands in shame in 1583
fortunately for Francis though he
wouldn't have to live with the shame for
too long since he died in 1580 for this
was a big deal because Francis had been
the heir to the throne since Henry the
3rd didn't have any children that left
another man as his heir King Henry of
Navarre
the Protestant one if you thought the
Catholic nobility in France were worried
before well now they were downright
hysterical in response to this crisis
the Duke of Gea's the son of the
previous one formed the Catholic Lee to
stop Henry of Navarre from ever taking
the throne
it was comprised of some of the most
devout Catholic Nobles across France and
was backed that is financed by King
Philippe ii of spain who was also pretty
scared of the idea of a protestant
france
king henry was bankrupt and he couldn't
really resist the leak and so to placate
them he issued the Edict of namur in
1585 this essentially made being a Hyuga
no illegal and gave them six months to
convert or leave France the Duke of
geese in the league were expelling huge
eNOS from the north but also we're
telling French subjects that Henry
wasn't a true Catholic since he refused
to bar a Protestant from the succession
and to accept their appointed heir
Cardinal Charles de borbón Henry of
Navarre zonko in 1587 France yet again
erupted into its eighth war of religion
but it's better known by another name
the War of the three Henry's a German
army invaded the north to aid the
Protestants but was defeated by the Duke
of qeej who became incredibly popular as
a result he demanded a bunch of land and
titles as thanks for his victory the
King said no and also barred keys from
Paris he's entered anyway and the people
of Paris rose up in defiance with him in
what's known as the day of the
barricades and the king fled the city in
1588 the King called the Estates General
at the Grand Parliament of France to
meet in bra whilst there he had keys
assassinated and arrested some
high-ranking members of the league and
as such the league was now at war with
the king thus King Henry and the other
King Henry made a truce they combined
their forces and marched on Paris in
1589 Henry the 3rd was close to taking
the city until he was assassinated by a
monk and with him died the Royal House
of Valois
according to French royal inheritance
law called salic law Henry of Navarre
was now king and the first Protestant
King of France henry pressed his claim
to the throne and marched on Paris he
laid siege to the capital with M
philippe ii sent an army into france
which broke the siege fighting continued
for the next couple of years but Henry
the fourth won out in the end for two
reasons one the Cardinal of bourbon died
and the Lea couldn't decide on another
successor and two henry converted to
catholicism in 1593 the next year henry
was crowned King Henry the fourth of
France the first of the Royal House of
Bourbon
resistance to Henry's rule continued but
was largely crushed within a year the
fact that the Spanish crown was largely
responsible for this resistance led to
Henry declaring war on it the war came
to an end in 1598 but not until Henry
had issued the Edict of norm which gave
recognition in
equal rights to Protestants across
France providing they remain loyal to
the crown the edict was a series of wins
and losses for the Protestants and the
Catholics whilst no site was truly happy
with it the level of resistance to it
was much lower than before because at
this point everyone was sick of war
Hyuga knows couldn't prevent Catholics
from worshipping in their strongholds
like Clara shell and had to pay taxes to
the Catholic Church
however they were allowed to remain
armed and they could hold their own
councils these ultimately weakened
Henry's authority across his kingdom but
not did something that the other edicts
didn't it built a lasting peace
that is until louis xiv realized that he
didn't need to keep that peace anymore
whilst this didn't put a stop to the
religious tensions in france it did end
its most violent period which saw
millions of Frenchmen die the French
Wars of Religion were finally over in
France unlike so many others would
remain a Catholic nation Hereafter I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching the special thanks to
Winston Cawood Adam Harvey Skye
Chappelle James Bissonnette as ARCA
Flash and Henry Robin if you'd like to
learn more about the French Wars of
Religion then there's a couple of
recommended books in the description
below